No to the second part,
it's quite different.
So it's told mapping.
This is concerned in our,
so before we had a optimization
for the light simulation,
now we'll will look at the very
end of our rendering pipeline.
So the issue of showing the
image output on a display
because the problem is that
alight simulation outputs
radiants so it's the how
much light travels along one direction
when it comes from a small surface page.
So you collect radiance with your camera,
record it,
but somehow your display
expects RGB values.
So the radiance can carry some
curling formation. So you could,
for example,
um,
trays the are the g the B value,
uh,
general independently.
You can do something with more
fidelity like spectral ray tracing.
So you trace rays that um,
were not only radiance is
carried along the rape,
but spectro radiance.
So gradients of a certain
wavelength of the light.
This,
for example,
you can see this effect in prisons
where you split white light into rainbow
colors.
So if you do not perform spectral ray
tracing there and just assume we have
white radiant,
then you cannot simulate this effect
because the, then the reflection,
so the rage geometry changes with the
wavelength that's associated to it.
So your refraction angles get different
and this causes the split into the
rainbow colors.
So,
but in some way you
have radiant as output.
So to show them on this
place or to bring them,
you need to convert your images.
Some are from Radians to RGP and there
is an inherent problem with it because
radiance of light simulation have a huge
range because they tried to simulate
real world physics.
And in real world you have a huge
difference between dark and bright.
So for example, if you take, um,
the ratio between the surf
between a surface at say,
ground level in the earth atmosphere
that is either illuminated by the sun or
the moon,
the differences effect of $800.
And then he mentioned that the patch
of the ground is either white or black.
This courses and other different in
the reflected radiants quantities of
approximately a factor 100.
So if you want to do,
say,
a Chandler light simulation,
and you can expect that elimination
by Sun and moon should be in there,
white and black surfaces
should also be in there.
You have to somehow cold with a ratio
between the darkest and the brightest
values of 80 million.
MMM.
So is it relevant to do that?
So can people even see the
difference between that?
And yes, they can. So since
these are highly relevant,
um,
features of our world to differentiate
dark from bright especially and the very
bright and dark conditions,
so imagine a cave men
in the woods at night,
it will be very good to see small
contrast differences that could indicate
predators. So there
was a evolutionary, um,
forcing to develop,
to develop a visual system that,
um,
also can take advantage of this huge
dynamic range of radiants values.
So for example,
how this is built up.
So photoreceptors in our eyes,
they have a chemical bleaching when
they are hit by light particles.
So this can be regulated biochemical
to enable adaptation in a range of two
orders of magnitude.
So just by regulating the CPO
chemical properties of photoreceptors,
you can adapt the I to a rain.
The difference in dark and bright of 100
the pupil size gives you another order
of magnitude.
So a factor of 10 and the neural
adaptation is more or less the signal
processing.
So what to do actually with the changing
signal because your receptors get
bleached. So the dynamic range of human
vision is approximately 100 million.
So that means that we can perceive in
fact the dynamic range of realistic
conditions on in our atmosphere.
But
then you have,
so the output of the light,
if it takes this into account can be,
it can have a difference of 80 million
fixed of 80 million between dark and
bright and 10 you want to
show this on the display.
So the technology for a standard display
gives you a dark too bright ratio of
approximately 1000 and if you use
eight feet in Kolding of your values,
then you only have 265
values for it beat chambers.
That means that somehow our technology
is immensely inadequate to show realistic
scenarios.
It's all great.
This is also good because you
get not blinded by your display,
but we have to somehow account for that.
So just taking the radiance output
and converting it trivially,
two images will carry
some problems with it.
Yeah,
usually big bitmaps files or [inaudible].
Um, but um, usually you'll have, um,
you split them into the different colors.
So you have eight weeks for our
eight weeks for g h big floppy.
And you can somehow imagined that this
gives you how much red light is at this
pixel. And Yeah, you call 206. I mean,
of course for the whole color
gamut you have more venues.
But if you just look at the dark
brighter ratio of a single college,
this is approximately what you have.
So
now Tom mapping is the methods that
was developed to combat this problem.
So the output of a light
simulation as already said,
high dynamic range because of the of
real world dynamic range of brightness,
values and display devices
usually have a low dynamic range.
So what do we need to do is to
compress the range of alt book somehow.
And this is referred to as added
tone mapping, a tome reproduction.
So these are the names that
you find in the literature.
MMM,
there are two issues here.
One is range compression.
So how to convert high dynamic range
luminant's to load and they make range
luminance.
This is the content of this
lecture and then you still have um,
Luminance's,
but usually there are standardized
color spaces in which images are stored.
So you don't store your own,
um,
hold rooms format,
which takes certain
wavelength and thank yous,
the luminance values for those,
but they are standardized ways to do that.
And this is covered in a different
lecture about color. You'll see the,
um,
lecture number here.
So I refer you to this lecture if you
want to know more about color in here.
Now I only,
um,
explain range comparation to some extent.
So
okay,
now, uh, um, graphic example.
So here we have a bright as single bright
light source with no ambient light in
the scene. That means that all, um,
contrast comes only from this one
light source via global illumination.
Okay.
So if you take,
if you would photograph the
scene and take a short exposure,
this is what your kit.
So all the um,
dimly illuminated parts
completely disappear in blech.
Okay?
And, but you see, um,
details in previously to bright scenes.
So that led to over exposure
of your camera. So for example,
here you now see the um,
the outline. So the senior
editor of the bulb, for example,
okay,
a very long exposure leads to uh,
our overexposure of most of the image.
So you do not see any detail anymore
close to the lamp or ad directly
illuminated surfaces.
But what you see is that previously dimly
illuminated objects in the background
now are whale perceivable.
Okay?
So this is what you get if you take only
a small part of it dynamic range and
map those to an image.
And what could you do to combine all this
information into one image so that the
most trivial thing you can imagine is I
just divide by the maximum of the scene.
This gives me a nice, um, Newman
ends values from zero to one.
And this I can make to
whatever range I want.
The problem with this is that usually the
maximum is not indicative of the whole
scene.
The maximum is usually extremely bright.
So when you're divided by the maximum,
the only thing you see is as a single
reflection in the close to the light bulb.
Okay.
If your Clampett,
so let's say I have arrange of
enters that I'm interested in.
Everything below is,
is clamped by a Ciro.
Everything above my maximum that I
decide to have is completely white.
This is exactly the problem that that
becomes obvious with high dynamic range
that parts are underexposed,
other parts are way exposed.
So clamping also doesn't
get you something. You have
to take the whole range.
You cannot just ignore certain parts.
So one approach that
gives you nice resources,
explanation mapping,
they are us zoom at exponential
distribution in your, um,
luminance values.
And then rescale is exponential
function into a linear one.
That means that, um, very bright values,
it gets cave down low. Alias
gets scaled up, but you,
you account for the very bright spots.
So these are the things
that gets caged the most.
So the pride values at the
bow get some reasonable white,
but they do not dominate the whole scene.
Um,
and more sophisticated approaches.
The Reinhart told mapper
developed by Reinhardt, the guy.
Um, and this is um,
this is the one example that they
will present in this lecture. Um,
as you can imagine,
there are many NATO members.
So everyone tried to um,
do some approach that works very
well for a certain subset of scenes.
Some,
um,
methods were optimize to four
parallel hardware or for certain um,
hardware architectures
to give more speed there.
Sam presented rough approximation
that work in real time.
So there is already a quite wide
bunch of tone may pose to choose from.
Um, that I end how tone may
is one of the most common.
So if you're look into some at our open
source or commercial rendering software,
this is usually one of the
things to this implement.
So, um, entity,
there is also some additional
information to put this into context.
Um,
there is some,
um,
some approach in digital
photography to take, um,
multiple exposure images.
So to combine,
um,
exposures of the same scene
that are taken with different
exposure times into one image.
So this is called high dynamic range
photography and usually to use similar
methodologies.
So the iron hot tone mapa can also be
used to combine or for HDR photography.
But if you put a HDR
photography into Google,
you usually end up with images like that.
And this is not for Tom may
pick is about tone mapping is a
perceptually and physically validated
approach that gives you realistic
impressions of the scene and
it's not an artistic effect.
So it's not that you take tone
mapping, look at the image and say, ah,
I would like to have it to have more
contrast in there and then you change your
tone member. I mean, this is
not, it didn't stand at use.
And the community of HDR
photography to a large extent over,
uh, uses this capability
of the system. For example,
this photograph here is a completely
botched implementation or use of Hdr,
uh,
range compression for example,
things that you see that are not correct.
Um,
the halos around the balloons.
So sadly,
why the sky is brighter around
the silhouettes of the balloons.
This is, um, this is, uh,
an effect that is present in the
visual system to some extent,
but not to this extent.
So this is,
some people think that this is nice,
nice HDR photography,
but this is just wrong.
Simply a state.
If you like that your
images look like that,
then this is an artist's
decision not told, met big.
This is just, yeah, contrast
enhancement, you can call it.
Also the colors in this image,
uh,
get screwed up because
they are not oversaturated.
So this is just a warning. The tone
mapping the during counter for, um,
lights in relations should not look like
that because then you have arr in your
application. Yeah. If
I mean this, this is a combination
of the forensics cultures.
Now it's,
I mean it,
it is a combination of different exposures
and it's taken with a tone mapping
approach and you have to
do the combination somehow.
It said before you can add a device with
a maximum and combined them clamping.
But,
um,
usually the toll paper give
you a more realistic result.
For example,
why is it obvious that here
already multiple exposures were combined?
Because in the very left
of the left,
you see that you still see some kind
of detailing the boot in behind,
but at the same time use,
you can call us direct look into the
sun without having blood off the screen.
So that means that already a huge
dynamic range was compressed here,
but it should not look like that.
It should look like that
if it's done correctly.
Yeah.
And this would be the correct
application for this photograph.
So it looks a whole realistic.
It doesn't oversaturate the colors.
It only has a very,
uh, light, uh, halo around the cigarettes,
which is also an effect that's
present in the visual system.
Okay.
So this is what you
should aim for. So, um,
now about tone mapping itself.
Um,
there are two large different classes.
So one or the global total
Mack was and the other local,
so the Global Tome map was used a mapping
function that converts radiums at a
certain Pixel to say RTP value.
If you select this color space and
this mapping functions uniform,
what I mean here is not that it's uniform,
it produces the uniform output value.
So you don't get a image
with a single color value,
but the function it's safe just takes as
input the radio into certain pixel and
the old codes are Gbv and these
functions than used four pixels image.
Okay.
Um,
more complex methodologies are local.
Told me papers,
which not only take the a
single pixel into account,
but also it's in via its neighbors.
Okay.
Um,
this is,
this is perceptually motivated because um,
Seo have seen before,
that's called trust or brightness
adaptation of your eyes in the,
in the photo receptors for example, this
is done locally, so it single fault,
the Resectr attempts to
different brightnesses.
So that means that you
told mapping in the human,
I use a local behavior.
Um,
but they are, are, um,
there are reasons to employ both of them.
So the Global Tome mappers,
the are fast because they have a
single mapping function. So you take,
you can execute this function
parallel on each pixel.
So this makes it perfectly usable
for GPU approaches, for example.
But you're encouraged some loss of detail
because you cannot locally look as if
the,
is this already a dark patch of my scene
so I can enhance the country's more
there?
Or is it at a dark,
bright boundary where I
do not do it that much?
And the local, uh, don't mappers.
And nowadays, so they allow
a local contrast enhancement,
but they are slope because you're not
only have to say, look at the big four,
but also its neighborhood.
The neighborhood grows a quarter
ethically if you enlarge it.
So, um, the,
you incur a different
complexity in your problem.